now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
introduce a couple of constructions onto
this which are going to help me
understand how in particular
psy and tan behave at the origin when
the values of feet are get very very
little so I'm sort of trying to
understand this thing over here so I've
got my tangent I've got a radius there
I'm going to introduce a feed on
okay now the thing that I want it has to
be acute I'll show you why in a second
so I'm going to draw a line often young
and that make something up over there
okay the reason why I want an acute
value for theta is because if fear is
equal to ninety degrees or more this
line that I just drew here right this
horizontal one it's never going to
intersect with the tension do you see it
because it every parallel you'll just go
off this way right and then meet before
we go off put it that way and it would
be somewhere up here and I don't want
that I need a I'm gonna have an
inequality for me with geometry over
here so choose some kind of acute value
of theta and now what I've got here what
I've formed is well some interesting
shapes in here number one I have this
triangle that I formed right I also have
epr I've got a stepped-up that is
smaller than that triangle if you see
the sector's inside the triangle sorry
inside the central of the triangles
outside
so therefore the sector must be smaller
and one more thing that I'm going to add
in is another triangle but inside the
sector okay so I'm kind of um I'm kind
of doing it which we've got the dolphin
thing right where I've got increasingly
small things as I keep wandering in and
thus the things that are inside must be
smaller like otherwise they wouldn't fit
inside okay so in order I have this big
triangle out here and I'm on a sector
and then I got this little triangle in
the middle
okay I want to be able to talk about all
of these so being at this line over here
is a tangent I'm gonna call this point
here T so that I have some names for my
shapes
alright now let's go through these one
at a time to make this simpler for us
I'll do the ones we tricky just chord
right we'll start from the inside if I
think about this area of triangle payer
be a that's the inside one okay it's a
circle you don't know anything about two
measurements so let's just call its
radius ha what is the area of that
triangle
oh yeah I mean he's half a B side C
which in this case is half a big sign C
so half us a square inside there okay
good that was easy just as easy to quote
and it's important we're dealing with
radians here so therefore if I talk
about not trade or arabi but sector
Arabi I know a formula for this dough
line right what's the area of the sector
that's not complicated now we kind of
need to do a bit of an intermediate step
to get the area of the bigger triangle
that third third shape there right I
suppose I could try do some half a piece
on seating here but being that this is a
right angle that makes a or T is
triangle a right angle triangle
so therefore if this is a right angle
triangle and if it's perpendicular here
that makes this are the perpendicular
height if I make the base we all have to
put the base in order to make that the
perpendicular height
yet this would have to be the base right
so what's 18 what am I gonna do to work
out 80 here I know a sign I know what
angle this isn't I know yeah good idea
you've got an angle I mean you've got
the opposite side and you've got any
adjacent side so that sounds like tan to
me doesn't complicate so I'm going to
say in that triangle a tee right when
you're pulling out your right angle
triangle treat formulas ratios you
should always take the triangle that
you're in because I've got a whole bunch
of them right in that triangle like you
said tan of theta is opposite on
adjacent which is 80 on well it's just
the radius is the adjacent side so
that's really good because now that just
kind of hangs me the base in a very nice
form great convenience that's all I
needed to find though what was I give
you fault
area of the triangle so I'm going to go
area on triangle egg booty it's 1/2 base
times height that's the base and that's
the heights so you can see the odds
going to flip
okay thanks now remember we set off by
saying up a three shapes right one two
three and they all nested within each
other right so what is your width in
this Sun so long as your acute so long
as feeder is less than pylon - you're
going to get these three shapes and
they're always going to be in this size
order I'm in ascending order at the road
okay so therefore I can say because this
is less than this which is us miss I can
form one big inequality with all of
these right I can say therefore half R
square sine theta is less than R square
to figure out which is less than half a
square continue so this is brilliant
because remember what I'm trying to
understand is the behavior of the origin
and now I have all three of these guys
together in one relationship because of
this babushka don't think about creative
okay I only need to do a couple of
things in order to now to try and get
towards the origin to figure out what
happens when theta gets very small okay
firstly I wanna get all these hot R
Squared's another way right and I can
simply divide through why can I do that
because half R square is more so long as
it's not zero I can divide through and
so long as it's positive which it better
be it's not gonna muck around my
inequality signs yeah so I'm gonna go
like that and I'm gonna say the reason
why is because earth R square is
positive okay that's good now I'm going
to do one more thing which is a little
counterintuitive but like it seemed like
why would I do this but you will see why
in a second it produces a very very
simple result I'm going to divide
everything through by sine theta that
will give me here one that'll give me
here to feed up on sine theta
oh and on the right hand side this is
site on clauses in it I've just divided
by sine this is one cause there is that
okay I mean I could write that as a sec
if I want to but it is there are you
guys okay my juices now I should say the
reason I can divide through by sine
theta is because remember I said feet is
an acute angle
it's not clown to and it's not zero
either right that's the only value in
this domain which would make zero so
therefore I can divide through because
that is true now I'm there now this is
what I need is piece here it doesn't
look obvious but now I can take those
inequalities and I can examine their
behavior at the origin
don't forget I have this sunny right I
have this restriction on feet up okay so
being a seat has to be positive I'm
going to do a limit here but I can only
perch in one direction does that make
sense
like I can only approach from the
positive direction
yes following me my feet it can't be
over there so therefore I'm going to say
take this whole thing everything and
think about its limit as the years
approaching zero but from the positive
direction so I need to write a plus bag
I'm gonna take that limit of everything
thank you
so I have three things I'm gonna take
three limits
zero all rights of one of what yeah okay
now look at this beautiful little object
it looks a bit complicated than a bit
but watch what happens to it that thing
on the left-hand side just because it so
what happens to it when theta approaches
zero nothing happens to it it just stays
one it doesn't give a rip with your duty
okay this guy here this guy here is
actually the object of interest so I'm
going to just leave it as is like Sun
now have a look at the guy on the right
usually we have issues with limits
because we talk about limits cuz you
can't just evaluate theta at that
whatever value right but because here I
have cos theta cos theta is well defined
when Z when T is equal zero right cos
theta is coming up to one right so this
guy is one over one it's just one right
now look at this
hold on what just happened okay I have
something unknown but I know it's being
squeezed between we've done this before
it's being squeezed between these two
things that look to me like they are the
same so therefore I can say this guy
here
this ratio is equal to one this is a big
deal what we're doing cracking right and
we're trying to like put functions
together and compare them and think
about like Oh which one gross possum is
to the Apes skirt pasta or is x-squared
great FAFSA well just log X go faster
you know you know how we try to do this
comparison right and sometimes we think
about shrinking it now if you think
about linear graph and a sine curve
right we're thinking about what happens
toward the origin
now clearly they're both shrinking which
one is shrinking faster and the answer
is when you compare them they are
shrinking at exactly the same rate okay
when I say great that's your cue then
when we go to calculus it's gonna be a
really good field okay now that I write
one more thing I'm taking up which is
that um I actually want to know about
the origin I want to just know about one
side of the origin so I'm gonna put a
little tricky remember on this morning I
said the tree expansions you can go from
the sign a plus beta some just sign a
minus B using what knowledge what did we
used to convert one to the other we use
a lot of even functions right now have a
look at this guy is this an odd or an
even function now if this is f of theta
oh no then F of negative theta will be
minus theta on sine of minus theta which
is odd there's a none function there
right so that's gonna become negative
theta on negative sine theta that looks
like the original F to me
so f sure enough is even if this is an
even function and I come for the right
hand side and it does that then what
should happen if I come from the other
side and it's not exactly the same thing
right so I can say since theta on side
views even I get the same behavior
coming from the left so I got a theta
approaches your from the other side
and now I'm finished now I can put them
two together and say you know what if
these are pressuring zero it doesn't
matter we're coming from this makes
sense because look at what these two
graphs look like and which direction
you're coming from this is going to be
one one's a special right here because
it's it's own reciprocal right one is it
fun reciprocal so that means that in
fact if you were thinking about it the
other way around you're going to take
the reciprocal one side which means you
take the reciprocal off the other side
which is one